- I like to know that I can define my fame
and define my beauty for myself.
If you are always changing what you do
based on what other people say,
you completely lose yourself.
Making it is important,
but it's not more important
than keeping plans with
your grandma and your dad.
I put a lot of time and
effort into everything I do,
to the point that I do nothing else.
- She's an American singer,
songwriter, and actress.
She's one of the best-selling
musicians of all time,
with over 27 million albums sold.
Her achievements include
12 Guinness World Records,
and six Grammy Awards.
She's Lady Gaga, and here's my take
on her Top 10 Rules for Success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick around all the way
to the end for some special bonus clips.
Also, as Lady Gaga is talking,
if she says something that is really
inspiring or meaningful to you,
please leave it and write it
down in the comments below
and put quotes around it,
so other people can be
inspired by the message as well.
(jets blasting off)
- I just always felt famous,
that's what my first
album was really about,
is that fame comes from inside of you,
and it's not something that you obtain.
And I still feel that
way, in a lot of ways.
I like to know that I can define my fame,
and define my beauty for myself.
Which is why I'm so
vigilant and relentless
about my image and my music is
I will not allow, no matter
how successful I become,
for the public to define or indicate
what it is that I create, or what it is
that I believe is
beautiful, or what I believe
is a hit pop record.
That's who I am, and I
will always be that way.
Relentless and fearless and vicious.
I'm my own artist, I have my own vision.
♫ Can't read my poker face
I suppose that there's one interpretation
of the female to sing a
love song and look pretty
and just, you know, I
guess do what everyone
thinks you should do.
But it's just not what inspires me,
and I'm inspired not just by what I see
in terms of the future of
music, or tech, or fashion,
I see also my fans, and I think about
what they want to
experience, and they love
to feel out of touch with
reality for a moment.
So it might feel shocking, maybe,
but I really think it's just this sort of
surreal fantasy that I take
pleasure in creating for you.
Someone asked once what
they, or many times, I think
what I thought it meant to be an artist,
and I said, what I think an
artist needs, essentially,
more than discipline, or even
talent, is a perspective.
So if you are always changing what you do,
based on what other people say,
you completely lose
yourself, and you become
just, you know, something
that's constantly affected
by what's around you, as
opposed to stable and your own,
and autonomous in your identity.
I've been making music now
with, you know, Tony Bennett
for a couple of years, and
Elton John is, you know,
one of my closest friends,
and his husband, David.
They just have showed me that
I'm a baby in my artistry.
And I just have to keep
making music and keep going.
So my focus, really, for this
album is showing that, to
to young girls, and to boys,
that want to make music,
that you don't have to
get lucky on the internet,
it's not a social media
game, you don't have to find
the hot producer, and get
the hot track to be a star.
You can just learn how
to play an instrument
and sit in your room, and practice,
and write songs and
poetry, and then you can go
around the corner to the
bar and meet other artists
that do the same thing that you do,
and you can hang out and talk
about music and write songs,
and then you can play at
the spot around the corner,
gain one fan, and then do it
over and over and over again
until you're discovered.
For me, you know, I did say in
that skit that the other way
to earn applause is to earn it.
- Hard work.
And discipline, and rehearsal.
That's always the most
thrilling way to earn applause.
And everything that you've seen me do
I've always rehearsed a lot for it.
So, there's a lot of
passion that goes behind it.
- [Adam] When se was 17 years old,
Stefani got her high school diploma
and left the nuns to join the prestigious
Tisch School of Arts,
A school entirely dedicated
to artistic disciplines.
She took numerous classes, such as
Art Story, Music, Theater, and Dancing.
- I was really blessed
and lucky to get in.
I got in very early, I was 17,
and I was one of 20 people
in America that got into the school early.
And I was really happy and excited,
and I just felt like all
my dreams were coming true.
And it was a wonderful school, but,
it was very factory-like,
and not in the Warhol factory-like way,
more like a sausage link factory,
where everyone was taught
the same sorts of things,
and I think what I didn't
like about the school
was I felt that they wanted
us all to be the same
and possess the same skills, and,
I had something very
different inside of me.
- [Adam] Her days at
the Tisch School of Arts
were very busy, her evenings too.
Stefani made her debut as
a singer in New York bars.
♫ Holding on to love
Every night she would test out
and adapt her own compositions.
This experience enabled her to find
the secret to writing good songs.
Stefani made one of the most important
decisions of her life.
She decided to quit school,
and dedicate herself to music.
- What did they say, your
parents, when you left?
- My parents, well my mother
cried, and my father said,
"You have one year, and you
have to support yourself."
And I said, "Okay."
For me, I was never interested
in anyone taking care of me.
I even had a job when I was 15 years old,
because I liked to be independent,
I liked to do things on my own terms.
So, I left school and I
got three different jobs,
and my dad paid my rent for three months,
and then, when the three months was up,
I had to pay, and it was great.
It was wonderfully liberating.
- Is it difficult now, with the pressure,
I would feel, or think,
that there would be pressure
to continue to outdo
yourself, or to continue
to express yourself.
- There's always that pressure, but,
the best thing about it,
is it's only a door away.
It's like you, you know, I've
got the first album door,
it was open, it's great, door stays open,
I see it like a hallway (laughing)
That sounds, do I sound crazy?
- No you do not.
- It's a hallway with wooden doors.
The first door's open, that's that album,
you walk down, there's another door,
that's the next album, and then,
there's one more door,
and it's coming up, right?
And I'm banging on the walls,
and I'm looking for hammers,
I'm trying to figure out
where the machine guns are,
I just want to get to that frickin door.
- Door, right. But you know it's there.
- I know it's there, but can I open it?
It's not the same as just writing a song.
It's writing the next,
it's writing the next chapter
of whatever lobe is in my brain
that's waiting to be unlocked, and
if people think that I sound narcissistic
it's fine, because you know,
Oprah, it's all I've got,
is my creativity.
So I walk down that hallway and,
it happened recently.
- The door opened.
- The door opened. (laughing)
It opened, it blast
opened, and once it opens
the light shoots right through and I'm in.
And then I can relax, because I know
I broke through the door.
- So then you can, is
that when the words flow,
the lyrics, the harmony,
- It's the journey.
- Ah, got it.
It's the new journey of all of us.
- And is there something that you can do
to help the creative process,
the doors, open more readily?
Is there something you can do?
- I have a couple things that I do.
The newest thing that I do,
I don't read a damn thing.
No press, no television,
no if my mom calls and says,
"Did you hear about..."
I don't want to know
nothing, about anything,
that is going on in relation to music.
Obviously I want to know about the world.
I shut it all off, and other
than this interview, Oprah,
I do not intend to speak to
anyone for a very long time.
This is my moment, for me,
to experience a rebirth with my own music.
I have to shut it all out, the noise,
you know the noise.
The noise, it's loud, you
have to cancel out the noise.
And remember that it's
your thoughts that matter.
- You're so smart.
You are very wise.
- Well, you are wise.
- No, that's how you do
it. That is how you do it.
- You have to...
- Okay.
- I just learned how
much more wise I am now,
and how much I've learned,
and how important family is
and friendship, and how
your career and making it
is important, but it's
not more important than
keeping plans with your
grandma and your dad, you know,
and making sure that you are on time
for your mom's event that she's doing.
Whatever it is that you're working on,
that's what I've really learned
going into my, you know,
leaving my twenties, is
that it was time to have
more balance in my life.
How do I keep my ego in check?
I am always conscious of
empowering people around me.
I want everyone in my team
to know that they all play
the same, equal part that I play.
And making everything happen,
that happens every day.
This is my family.
They are my inspiration.
I'm a loyal bitch.
- Joanne!
(clapping and cheering)
I make it a very strong
effort, every second,
to be the nicest person that I can be.
- So let's look at some
of your headline-making
outrageous outfits that you designed.
Tell us about this one.
- Oh yeah, well that's Alexander McQueen,
and I added the hat to
it, it's an archive,
it's the oldest archive
in the McQueen collection,
and it was meant to be a continuation
of the VMA performance,
so after, I, the princess,
had been murdered by the paparazzi,
the red lace was meant to symbolize,
sort of, my eternal martyrdom.
- And this?
- Oh, well that's, you know,
that's Jean de Castelbajac outfit,
and I don't like to wear fur, so it was
my way of making a comment about fur.
Because it looks like a
bunch of dead muppets.
- Like a bunch of dead muppets.
- Yeah.
- Absolutely.
- Oh, that's the queen.
Well, I kind of wanted
to do an homage to the
queen, so that was my
Queen Elizabeth I outfit,
but it's made out of latex,
so it's still Gaga.
- Still Gaga.
So, do you spend a lot of time
thinking about it, or does it just come?
The outfits, the creative expression?
- The inspiration comes naturally, but,
I put a lot of time and
effort into everything I do,
to the point that I do nothing else.
I wake up in the morning and
I work creatively all day,
and all future things that I'm doing
- So what's a day like?
You're thinking about--
- I wake up in the morning
and I get on my computer,
and I have files, lists of references,
and I have reference boards with
all of my materials on them,
and I basically call the
House of Gaga all day,
and argue with them
about what I want to do,
while they tell me, "You can't do that."
And I say, "Yes I can bleed to death
on domestic television, if I want to."
For me, it's all about being
provocative is not just
about getting people's attention,
it's about releasing
something that affects people
in a real way, and in a positive way.
So, all the things that I
do, in terms of the fame,
and in terms of the fame monster,
it's meant to sort of make
it a bit easier to swallow,
this, kind of, horrific
media world that we live in.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Virginia Castillo asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know which of the rules
had the biggest impact on you and why.
What change are you going to make?
What realization did you come to,
after watching this video?
Leave it in the comments, I
will join in the discussion.
Finally, want to give a quick
shout out to Paul Bungard.
Paul, thank you so much
for buying my book,
it really means a lot to me.
For those of you watching,
if you want a chance
to get a shout out in a future video,
make sure to pick up a copy of the book
and email in your receipt
so we can keep track.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
Continue to believe, or
whatever your one word is,
and I'll see you soon.
(jets blasting)
- When she was little, and you
know kids when they're little
are like, "I'm going to be a singer".
Or, "I'm going to be an astronaut".
Did you ever, for one
moment, believe that she
would grow up to be as
big as she is right now?
- Actually, as a child, she was
very childish to begin with,
(laughing)
- [Host] As a child, a very
childish child, actually.
- But she was very determined, alright?
And we could see it in her
when she was four, you know--
- Oh I'm so embarrassed.
- She would stand in front of the piano
and just bang on the keys, and then
she wrote her first song,
I used to play "Money" by Pink Floyd,
and she wrote her first song,
it was called "Dollar Bill".
- [Host] I love that.
And Cynthia, my wife, she still has it.
- We should have that.
- Yeah, well. (laughter)
- It was because, you know,
on that record they use,
they use actual money, and
the register as instruments,
and I remember as a kid I
was so fascinated by that.
So my dad played me a lot of great music
that made me really fall in love
with that idea of making it.
My greatest influence in
this house, for ten years,
was Whitney.
- Really?
- Yes. And I used to stand
at the top of that staircase,
and sing "The Star Spangled Banner"
every single day after school.
I would play it over and
over and I would study--
- Her version of "The
Star Spangled Banner".
- And I used to stand up
there, and I would study her,
it's so interesting that
you brought that up, Mom.
It's like, I don't forget about it,
but I thanked her at the
Grammy's when I won that award,
because she, for me, is
the greatest of all time.
- Really?
- The greatest of all time.
I need to say thank you
tonight to Whitney Houston.
I wanted to thank Whitney because,
when I wrote "Born This Way",
I imagined she was singing it,
because I wasn't secure enough in myself
to imagine I was a superstar, so Whitney,
I imagined you were singing
"Born This Way" when I wrote it,
thank you.
- Will you look under the rock,
and will you search for
tweets, and search for
comments and see what people are saying?
- Well, you know, I like to
stay in contact with the fans,
and I want to see how they're
doing and enjoying the music,
and pick up on their
little artistic nuances,
the things that they
create and that they say,
but, I'm just in a
different place in my life
I don't allow things that are
negative to run everything.
I think it's important to
just try to stay grounded
in who you are, and the
things that come your way
just be grateful for them.